evening everyone welcome to the next
revolution i'm steve hilton and this is
the home of positive populism pro worker
pro family pro community and especially
pro america last week we laid out the
origins of wokism
the hateful intolerant ideology that's
captured
the most powerful institutions in
america with its cruel
cancelled culture it's as divisive and
poisonous as mccarthyism
but much more dangerous because it's not
just a deranged obsession of
here today gone tomorrow politicians or
some fad that exploded after the death
of george floyd
wokeism is the culmination of a campaign
that began
at frankfurt university's goethe
institute in 1923
to destroy the values and freedoms
america was built on specifically
targeting
faith family and culture because in the
eyes of the
critical theorists who invented what
became wokism
faith family and culture were the
bourgeoisies
tools of oppression and now here we are
wokism is today the biggest internal
threat america faces
it is the enemy within and it's
recruiting new allies all the time
the latest corporate america in the last
few weeks starting with the georgia
voting bill
the heads of major companies have
entered the political arena
as democrat activists they claim they're
not being
partisan and they're just defending our
democracy in the right to vote but when
they say that they're literally reciting
democrat talking points
there's no proposal in georgia or
anywhere else to undermine the right to
vote
these ceos are either lying
or wading into america's most
inflammatory issues
without knowing what they're talking
about the only actual proposal that
undermines democracy is the democrats hr
one
which among other anti-american horrors
unconstitutionally nationalizes
elections and pushes
banana republic atrocities like ballot
harvesting
which replaces one person one vote with
one union activist 500 votes
unbelievably corporate america is lining
up
behind this blatantly partisan power
grab
tonight we have a message for the woke
ceos you think you can
buy off the mob with pandering press
releases while business as usual
continues oh no
you want to behave like democrat
politicians fine that's how we'll
treat you you have no idea how painful
this is going to get
for your companies and for you
personally
let's start with ed bastian ceo of delta
airlines on march the 31st
he said georgia's new voting law will
make it harder for many underrepresented
voters particularly black voters to
exercise their constitutional right to
elect their representatives
that is wrong he said no ed bastian
you are wrong george's new law
makes it easier to vote in georgia and
easier
than in many democrat-run states but
facts are irrelevant to
delta's ceo who also said the entire
rationale for the bill
was based on a lie no ed bastian
your statement is a lie and the proof
you're a liar
is provided by your own company's
previous statement in support of
georgia's law
but ed bastian's dishonesty doesn't stop
there he took
our tax money in bailout dollars meant
to help employees working through the
pandemic
and gave it instead to managers
directors and senior vice presidents
what a nasty
piece of work but much worse is this man
brad smith president of microsoft his
disingenuous virtue signaling statement
also
implies that the georgia law undermines
the right to vote
why would he push such misinformation
because
brad smith is one of the most cynical
and corrupt operators in
all of corporate america for years he's
brought
off criticism and regulation by bribing
members of congress sorry
making donations microsoft has given
over 20
million dollars to republicans to
convince them that they're not part of
big
tech but on the biggest issue the one
that matters most for america's future
microsoft is worse than big tech every
republican member of congress every
staffer every conservative
policy maker who's been wined and dined
and financed by brad smith
listen to this china to view windows
code
china uses access to microsoft source
to help plot cyber warfare microsoft
just built a special version of windows
for china on and on it goes year after
year after year
microsoft the ally of our biggest enemy
china and now the ally of our most
dangerous
internal enemy wokism memo to every
republican lawmaker
microsoft is china soft
if you work with brad smith and
microsoft
you're siding with the enemies of
america
but it's not just microsoft you need to
cut ties with
this is coca-cola's utterly lamentable
ceo
james quincy in his abject capitulation
to democrat partisans he lined up
coca-cola
behind hr1 to rig the voting rules in
the democrats favor
preposterously he says it's to protect
black people's rights
but james quincy targets black people
black kids see more than twice as many
of his ads as white kids
james quincy increased his ad spending
over 80 percent in the last few years
despite multiple studies
linking his product to poor health james
quincy
encourages racism in his own company
coca-cola employees were told to be less
white as part of their diversity
training
in europe james quincy's coca-cola
cynically claims environmental plaudits
while continuing to be one of the
biggest polluters
of our oceans we'd take corporate
america's social justice activism
a bit more seriously if leeches like
james quincy
clean their own house first and here's
another
disgusting two-faced corporate hypocrite
blackrock's larry fink chief executive
of the world's largest investment firm
which is laughably
trying to wash its sordid reality
blackrock is concerned about efforts
that could limit access to the ballot
for anyone here
larry fink is so concerned about social
justice but apparently
not concerned enough to actually do it
in his own company just three percent of
his senior leaders are black
five percent of his us workforce now he
says he'll improve
but he co-founded blackrock in 1988.
what's he been doing all these years oh
look he's been
one of the biggest investors in private
prisons
which disproportionately hurt black
people he's been investing
in bomb manufacturers and profiting from
endless war and violence though he does
want us to know how much he's
in favor of gun restrictions just not
cluster bomb restrictions how woke is
that
about as woke as his personal behavior
apparently widely described by
euphemisms
for bullying maybe all this virtue
signaling is a desperate effort to save
larry fink from a me too reckoning who
knows
maybe someone will look into it but
larry's think
isn't the only sickening wall street
hypocrites step forward the grandest
and most pompous of them all jp morgan's
jamie
dimon voting must be accessible and
equitable he says
interesting a company so committed to
equity had to pay a 24 million dollar
settlement
to black financial advisors who accused
jp morgan of discrimination
secretly recorded conversations revealed
how a prospective jp morgan client was
essentially told he was
too black to be taken on and when
they're not discriminating against
people by race they're destroying local
communities and shipping jobs overseas
not just
as enablers of globalism but directly
themselves
they're even bribing public officials
which cost them a quarter of a billion
dollar settlement
in 2016. jamie dimon
who presides over this stinking cesspit
of corporate crimes against society now
says
companies like ours have an
extraordinary capability to help
not just with funding but with
developing strong public policy oh
fantastic
so instead of the people we elect it
will be the corrupt ghouls of wall
street writing our laws
a new corporate activism they call it
hey jamie diamond
why don't you do some activism on your
conscience why don't you larry fink
james quincy brad smith ed bastian and
all the rest
because you are everything that's wrong
with american capitalism
you make the rich richer the poor poorer
you crush small business you destroy
communities you despoil america's beauty
and yes
you disproportionately hurt black people
in this country so spare us
the woke virtue signaling it won't save
you from the mob but now you've joined
the democrats you can be sure the gop
won't save you from them either
when they raise your taxes you're on
your own when they crush you
with regulations you're on your own when
they break you up
and beat you down you are on your own
the new republican party a multi-racial
working-class coalition now holds
corporate america in contempt
so go ahead boycott their brands hound
their ceos
make their lives a misery that's the
next revolution we need